This title I didn't really realize I'd
be speaking to an audience that actually
included witches and wizards.
So
yeah.
Well probably I'll probably meet them in
question period.
That'd be my guess.
So can you all hear me?
One of you can hear me.
How's that?
That's better.
Okay.
Alright,
good.
Alright.
So
as you can plainly see,
the title of this talk is dragon's
divined parents,
heroes in adversaries are complete
cosmology of being
sounds,
dreadfully new age to me,
but it's not,
um,
new age.
People are very creative but they can't
think critically,
but I can think critically.
So this is a creative
theoretical enterprise,
conjoined with the capacity to tell the
difference between bad ideas and good
ideas.
And hopefully what I'm going to talk to
you about are the greatest ideas that
humanity has ever produced.
There are also ideas that we're,
we don't understand well and
who's highest level of formal
development.
We risk forgetting because we're
criticizing things that we,
we invented as a species,
but that we cannot understand rationally
and we're predisposed to believe that
ideas that we can't understand
rationally have to be wrong.
And sometimes that's true,
but sometimes we're just not smart
enough to understand them.
So
I can give you an example of something
that we're not really smart enough to
understand.
We're not really smart enough to
understand why people would line up for
four nights for 10 blocks to watch star
wars,
you know,
I mean,
they won't do that for a lecture
and they wouldn't pay money.
And so you know,
the star wars for example,
is naturally,
it's naturally interesting and people
just take that for granted.
But the fact that people will line up to
engage voluntary voluntarily in a ritual
activity of that sort
is a manifestation of something that's
very deep in the human psyche that we do
not comprehend.
Well.
So I'm going to talk to you about what I
like to think of as the grammar of
belief.
Okay.
I got interested in this.
Back in the mid eighties was driven
mostly by an interest in
global that was ideologically
motivated and also atrocity warfare was
not so difficult to understand in some
sense because you can map it onto animal
territoriality.
But atrocity in the service of videology
is a whole different thing there.
It's certainly clear that,
for example,
in World War II,
when the Nazis had to make a choice
perhaps between winning the war and
accelerating the rate at which they were
killing Jews,
they chose the latter and it's very
difficult to understand that using a
model based on animal territory quality.
I started reading about belief systems
widely
in
in political writings and economic
writings and religious writings.
The psychological writings,
anywhere I could find a thread that I
thought was promising.
I read a lot of young.
I read a lot of Freud,
almost all of the great clinical
psychologists,
a lot of soldier units and a lot of
George Orwell,
they're all people,
lot of Dostoevsky and niche.
If they're all people who,
as far as I can tell,
have something very original to say
and
out of that
are you learned to understand why people
need belief,
why it's actually inevitable.
Why faith and faith is inevitable.
Faith is inevitable in part because your
knowledge is finite and so you have to
take some things for granted or you fall
into an infinite regress
and what maybe constituted the
difference between pathological belief
and non pathological belief.
And those are terms by the way,
which I think can be defined
technically,
which is a statement that runs contrary
to the presuppositions,
say of moral relativism.
I'm definitely not a moral relativist.
Um,
I think it constitutes A.
I think the motivation for moral
relativism fundamentally is the desire
to abdicate responsibility even though
you can make very strong intellectual
cases for,
for why moral relativism is correct.
The intellectual case and the actual
motivation have nothing to do with one
another.
However,
I've also found out something else which
is quite interesting and I don't know
how much I can touch on it tonight,
but I don't think that Newton and Darwin
are commensurate.
I think that most modern people are
newtonians not Darwinians.
And I think that you can understand the
grammar of belief,
which is religious in nature using
Darwinian principles,
but it means that you have to give up
your Newtonian presuppositions.
And so I think I can make that argument
implicitly with what I'm doing as I
progressed tonight.
So the first thing I'm going to tell you
is that it's necessary for you to look
at the world through a limited frame of
on.
The reason for that is you're not very
smart.
Your consciousness can only handle about
four bits of information per second.
It's not very much given that the number
of bits of information coming at you
from next year and world are for all
practical purposes,
infinite.
You're like eldest Huxley suggested your
brain seemed to be primarily a reducing
agent.
Your body's a reducing agent as well
because there are lots of things that
you just can't detect and then the room
that you're sitting in is a reducing
agent because it's keeping all sorts of
things out that you would otherwise have
to deal with.
And the stability of this city as a
reducing agent.
Because we're not going to be stampeded
by barbarians with any luck at every
moment or any moment.
We.
We deal with the complexity of the world
in part by inhabiting a sequence of
reducing structures until the world is
reduced enough so that we can actually
deal with the minute elements of it that
we can comprehend at any one moment and
those elements we comprehend
are not the familiar objects of
objective reality.
In fact,
animals and people included are much
interested in objective reality.
We're interested in pragmatic reality
and pragmatic reality is the reality
that you act on,
not that you perceive and because we're
embedded in bodies and because we are
biological organisms and because we're
concerned with survival and reproduction
among other things,
how to act is a much more important,
much more important question for us then
what is the world constituted of
how to act in some senses?
Also the Prime Darwinian question,
right?
Because if you act
wrongly from a Darwinian perspective,
you end up dead before you can
reproduce.
So darwinism is a pragmatic
theory.
In fact,
the has eat the American pragmatists on
the North American east coast recognize
that
very short period of time after Darwin
studies were published.
They recognize the connection between
pragmatism as a theory and Darwinian
theory instantaneously,
so the world that we inhabit,
given that we're alive and given what's
selected,
selected us to act is actually a
pragmatic world,
and the objects of pragmatic worlds
aren't objects.
There are tools and obstacles and they
have valence,
a priority there.
They have value,
a priority from the Newtonian
perspective.
You look at the world
and then you think about the world that
you see the objects of the world that
you see and then you evaluate them and
then you act,
and that is not how your brain,
it's just wrong.
You might see the value of things before
you see the object itself.
I mean there are people,
for example,
who are blind.
They have blind sight.
They can recognize emotions on faces
without knowing.
They can see,
so that's partly because their retinas
are attached to the Amygdala.
Your retina is attached to a lot of your
body,
not just your visual cortex.
It's attached to your spinal cord.
It's attached to your nervous system at
multiple levels of analysis
simultaneously and so you can use your
eyes to detect things that you don't
know you're seeing so and what is in
some sense,
what you often detect under those
circumstances is valence value,
so you're very good.
For example,
at detecting teeth and predatory eyes
and the reasons for that are self
evident.
Fundamentally,
this is the smallest unit of meaning
that makes up a referential frame.
I think it has three elements,
one of which links the mind to the body.
Actually the mind body problem isn't
that difficult to solve if once you take
a pragmatic,
once you look at how the brain works
from a pragmatic perspective because
then your consciousness is fundamentally
something that's grounded in action and
you can understand the transition
between consciousness and action as a
sequence of of analysis that are
increasingly action oriented.
I'll talk to you about that a little bit
later,
but the basic framework is something
like this and you're always looking at
the world through this framework and the
framework has as one pole,
where are you are and what you're doing,
where you are now,
so that's quite a.
you're always trying to get from point a
to point b because you're a linear
creature and your embodied so you're
moving and so fundamentally what you're
looking at the world through is a
sequence of maps and maps tell you how
to get to where you want to go and so
the map specifies where you are because
obviously you can't get anywhere if you
don't know where you are.
And many people of course are confused
about where they are so they don't get
anywhere and you also have to know where
you're going and that's point a and
point b and every time you look at the
world,
you're looking through a framework that
has those two valued points.
Implicit in your cognitive structure and
generally what you think is where you're
going is better than where you are.
Because otherwise,
why would you go there?
Now,
some people do choose to go to places
that are worse than where they are,
but they're a special case.
You probably live with some of them.
Now when you're going from point a to
point B,
fundamentally you have to move.
Now,
movement is not abstract.
Movement is what you do with your body,
and so once your abstract representation
transforms itself into action,
you're no longer in the realm of
abstraction.
So in order to get from one place to
another,
you have to know where you are and you
have to know where you're going and then
you have walk,
fly,
run role.
You have to perform some sort of
embodied action to get there and of
course you have conscious control over
your voluntary muscular system,
but underneath that you don't really
have anything at all right?
You can move your arm,
you have no idea what muscles you're
moving.
So your conscious representation of your
body grounds out basically at voluntary
movement of the larger muscle systems.
So now you might ask,
well,
what does specify where you're going?
And the answer to that in large part is
biology,
but biology in a complex manner,
and this is where higher order morality
starts to become a concern.
You share with other animals all the way
down the phylogenetic chain,
various forms of of implicit motivation.
And you know you can kind of lump those.
It's arbitrary.
I lumped them into self maintenance
motivations and self propagation
motivations.
You know,
you can cut that in different ways.
Like I said,
it's more conceptual than than based on
say know anatomy.
But it'll do self maintenance.
Well,
you don't want to get too hot.
You don't want to get too cold.
Your hypothalamus deals with that very
old part of the brain.
It's way more important than your
cortex.
You can take the whole cortex off a
female cat and as long as you keep it in
a cage and it has its hypothalamus,
it can pretty much behave like a cat
except that it's hyper exploratory,
which is the last thing you'd expect
from an animal with no brain.
You can't be too hard,
you can't be too cold.
You got to regulate your water intake.
You have to eat,
you have to deal with the consequences
of eating,
you have to be with other people.
There's a place circuit,
a specialized place circuit.
There's a specialized erotic circuit,
there's a specialized circuit for
exploration,
which is about half of what the
hypothalamus does by the way.
Um,
and those,
those systems,
they've often been conceptualized as
drives,
but they're not really that.
They're more like isolated one I'd
personalities.
They're like cyclops.
They want one thing now they're not
stupid,
but they're not very amenable to
argument.
So when you're hungry and you're hungry
and you know,
another motivational system might object
to that,
but,
and that happens frequently,
which is partly why people are often
confused and also why you need a cortex
because you know,
you need a cortex to allow the competing
motivational systems to array themselves
properly and harmoniously across time so
that they all get their due instead of
fighting like two year olds in a room
because two year olds are basically
hypothalamic,
you know,
and so there are lots of fun,
but they're not organized and they're
not social at all.
So what happens with the motivational
systems,
very deep in your brain is they,
they specify the value of where you are
so that one of the values might be,
um,
I'm thirsty,
and then they tune your perception so
that things that are associated with the
quenching of thirst are much more likely
to be picked up by your system and they
bias your perceptual processing and your
evaluation towards the,
towards improvement of that motivation,
lack.
And,
and so you can't really think of them as
drives because they're way more
complicated than that.
They specify where you are.
So there's an element of self
consciousness that's associated with
that.
I'm thirsty and they specify a target.
Usually using fantasy.
You know,
you get thirsty,
you think,
well,
what would I like to drink?
And you get little fantasy about maybe a
glass of juice or a bit of water or
something like that.
And then your nervous system is tuned in
and you walk into the kitchen and you
ignore everything that's irrelevant to
the search for liquid.
And you focus in on everything that's
relevant to the search for liquid.
And that means you're so blind,
you cannot believe it.
I mean,
there's been many experiments now that
have shown that you can do things like,
I'm sure some of you have seen this,
you can introduce,
have gorilla into a basketball game and
60 or 70 percent of the people watching,
as long as they're paying attention to
the ball,
they won't see the gorilla.
And it's not like a little tiny gorilla
that somewhere off in the corner,
it's like main center,
six feet high beating its chest.
And even when you know that if something
else changes in the background,
you won't see that either.
So as far as you guys know,
that carpet could be changing colors 15,
20 times a minute.
You wouldn't even notice it unless you
had some weird obsession with carpets.
So,
okay,
so that's the beginning.
And in some sense of a universal system
of values.
Right?
And I can tell you how universal this
is.
I always have to tell this story because
it's so damn funny.
I just can't believe it.
So one of the things that your brain is
very concerned with his relative status.
That's why you're doing,
by the way,
which is partly why relative poverty is
often such a social problem.
People hate me and low in status,
especially men,
old male status hierarchies a bit
different than women and women are
pretty sensitive to status too,
but they use different markers anyways.
Part what happens when your status goes
up as your brain,
serotonin levels go up and when your
brain,
serotonin levels go up,
your last irritable and you and you
experience less negative emotion per
unit of uncertainty or threat,
and so when you know when you demean
someone and you interfere with and you
lowered the presumed status as far as
their very primordial circuit is
concerned,
you alter the system that regulates
their emotions and they hate that.
People hate that more than anything and
it's an unbelievably archaic circuit.
You can kind of tell this because
depressed people basically act like
they're low status and depressed.
People are depressed about everything
now.
It's not easy to be depressed about
everything.
Right?
And so the fact that that's the case
means that what's ever gone astray has
to be very primordial because it affects
everything anyways.
People often use antidepressants to cure
depression,
hence their name.
I'm and antidepressants decrease the
rate at which Serotonin is taken back up
by the neurons that produce it.
Well,
300 million years ago,
crustaceans emerged and crustaceans live
in dominance hierarchies even though
they're not particularly social.
And if one lobster fights with another
and gets defeated,
then he won't fight with another
lobster.
Even when he beat for 20 minutes less,
you give them antidepressants,
in which case he'll fight again right
away.
The reason I'm telling you this is
because the status structure that
underlies your being not just your
brain,
but your being is is so old.
You share it with crustaceans,
so you mess with it at your peril.
It's not learned by no means.
So anyways,
you wander around inside one of these
little frames going from point a to
point b all the time.
And one of the annoying things about
life,
and this is sort of this is a story,
is that as soon as you climb from point
a to point b and you get there,
then there's another point and another
point b.
and that's pretty interesting too,
because one of the things that suggest
is that getting somewhere isn't really
what people want because as soon as you
get somewhere,
then you're done going there and then
you have to get somewhere else.
So in some sense it seems it's an
accomplishment,
another sense.
It's just the next rock up the mountain.
Now you all know this because you know,
you graduated from university and that
was a good day,
but the next day you weren't a
university student,
you were some unemployed,
loser,
you know.
And so,
and that's uh,
you know,
that sets up a whole new set of
problems,
right?
I mean,
that's how the frame shifts and when the
frame shifts like that,
then the value of everything shifts
around it.
So it turns out that people are actually
more interested in getting from point a
to point b,
then they are in actually being at point
b and almost all of the positive emotion
that you feel,
which is related to dopaminergic
circuitry by the way you experienced in
relationship to the pursuit of a value
goal rather than to the attainment of
the goal.
The attainment of the goal actually
satisfies you,
or more specifically,
it satisfies that motivational circuit,
but then the damn thing just shuts off
and another one starts yelling at you,
so it's like a perverse form of victory.
So one answer to that.
That's universal in some senses that you
should establish a relationship with a
transcendent value because it never runs
out of motivational power.
You can see an example of that popular
example in Popular Culture in the
Pinocchio Movie,
which are.
How many of you have seen that?
Yeah.
Is anybody not seen it?
Hm.
That's amazing.
Anyways,
in the Pinocchio Movie,
one of the things that happens is when
Japan wishes that his son becomes a full
developed individual instead of a damn
puppet,
this is a good thing for a parent to
wish by the way he wishes upon a star
and the star something of transcendent
value.
And so the meaning of that fundamentally
is that if you want to raise your child
to be an independent being,
that you better set your sights on
something transcended or it won't
happen,
and believe me,
there's lots of times it doesn't happen.
So part of the utility of a transcendent
value is that never loses it's
motivational effectiveness.
Now you might say,
well,
that's no proof that there are
transcendent values.
It's like,
yeah,
that's true.
But there's more to the story.
Okay,
so when you're in one of these little
stories,
which is basically what they are,
they're the simplest story.
I was one place I went by this means to
another place.
That's the simplest story.
It's not that exciting.
Much more exciting story is I was going
from point a to b and something weird
happened and then I didn't know where I
was and then I was like in chaos for,
you know,
two years.
And then I figured out how to climb out
of it.
Everybody likes that story,
right?
That's a death and rebirth story by the
way,
or a fall from paradise story with a
regaining of paradise at the end,
you know,
it's an archetypal story because
everyone lives it.
And so anyways,
when you're in one of these little
stories,
frames of reference,
what you see in front of you are really
things that one of the best scientists,
whoever studied visual perception,
called the book's called ecological
approach to visual perception.
He called them affordances.
Affordance is something that affords you
something and affordances can be
positive or negative.
I like to think about them as tools or
obstacles.
So for example,
if I need to make a beeline for that
door,
you guys are all instantly obstacles.
And the way I would respond to that
implicitly is that you'd all be
negative.
So imagine we just said fire.
Well you were people the minute before
that,
but the second after that,
your obstacles and your emotional
reactions to the people that are in
front of you are going to reflect that.
Now you all know that because you drive,
you know,
and once you're encapsulated in your
little insectoid shell and don't have to
deal with the immediate responses of
other people,
you're going to treat them like
obstacles and like demonic obstacles at
the drop of a hat.
And you know,
that's pretty much automatic behavior.
So tools are things that get you to
where you want to go.
And you remember,
you know,
human beings are tool using animals par
exsalonce,
right?
We're so tool using that.
That's what we see.
It's built right into us.
We're always scanning the world for
tools.
When you look at gravel,
for example,
what you actually see are throwing sized
rocks.
That's why they manifest themselves as
that kind of object in the environment.
You know you're built at a certain level
of resolution and the way your nervous
system parts parses up the world is into
things that are useful for you and
things that aren't.
And those are not objects.
The whole idea of object is a very,
very modern derivative of that much more
primordial system.
And it's by no means clear at all that
our notion of object is more real than
the notion of affordance.
In fact,
as far as your brain is concerned,
objects,
no one cares about objects.
What your brain cares about is
affordances and what your brain is
adapted to is the world as a set of
affordances,
as obstacles.
And if you're a Darwinian,
it's very difficult to escape the
conclusion that what selected you is
reality,
and so if the reality that selected you
shaped you so that what you see are
affordances and obstacles or you die,
then it's perfectly real proposition,
perfectly reasonable proposition to
state that what reality is in fact is a
set of affordances,
tools and obstacles.
And that is how your brain works.
By the way,
when you look at,
say I look at that projector,
maybe I'm thinking about picking it up.
What happens is my eyes activate the
part of my motor cortex that would
adjust my hand to grip it like that.
And so part of what I understand as the
projector is grippable object and that's
not a secondary derivation.
I don't see the object and then think
this is how I would grip it.
It's like that would take forever.
You know,
you'd never catch a baseball if that's
what you were doing.
It's like,
oh,
a round object is punk.
You know?
It's like,
that's just not gonna work.
You're really,
your,
your nervous system is nowhere fast
enough to do that consciously.
You're using reptile circuitry to catch
baseball's the mammalian stuff is too
damn slow.
So you catch the ball often.
Especially if someone pitches it fast
before you could even see it.
You just think you saw it.
You see it after you caught it.
The case with tennis players too,
they went,
they seem to do is judge where the
ball's going to go by the angle of the
racket because if they wait until the
ball is off the racket,
they can't move fast enough to hit it
back.
They don't have the reflexes for it.
So they can't move the neural messages
fast enough to do it.
Okay.
So basically the world lays itself out
as tools and obstacles and you know,
obstacles make you feel bad.
But like let's say I'm looking at this
room and I'm thinking of you guys as
obstacles.
You might say,
well how bad does that make me feel?
And the answer to that is,
well,
not very bad because all I have to do
is,
you know,
make a circuitous route and I can get to
the door.
So then the fact that your obstacles is
a very minor impediment to the execution
of my plant,
and as a consequence,
it will produce a correspondingly low
level of negative emotion.
So you can think of those of known
unknowns in Rumsfeld's terms.
No one unknowns aren't that big a
problem because you can plan for them
and you might have a plan that's an
alternative plant that you can put in
place in case they show up.
What people really don't like.
Our unknown unknowns and unknown
unknowns.
You don't walk around those man,
they blow your whole map and your maps
quite complicated.
It's actually hierarchical in structure.
And I'll get to that because you know,
you go from point a to point B so that
you can go to a bigger point,
a to point b,
you know,
you crossed the road to get to the
library,
to study for an exam,
to pass the exam,
to get your degree,
to get a job,
to be a person,
to be a citizen,
to be a,
to have a good life.
So then if someone gets in your way
while you're crossing the road,
then to some degree they're interfering
with you getting a good life.
Now,
not very much,
but sometimes you'll react like that.
That certainly happens when you're
dealing with an intimate partner,
you know,
because they'll make some little mistake
and you'll say you always do that.
You're always,
you've always done that.
You always do it and you're always going
to do it,
which is really not a good way to
conduct an argument.
So unknown unknowns.
Well,
unknown,
unknown unknowns,
leap at you from places that you
wouldn't expect because otherwise you
would have planned for the damn things.
So there are the things that are always
poking their beak off at you when you
least expect it.
They're just like,
say serpents in the garden of Eden.
That might be one way of thinking about
it.
You can't keep the damn snakes out of
the garden and that's because you can't
make a bounded area and keep the
complexity out of it.
The complexity always sneaks back in.
Try protecting your children from the
Internet.
For example.
You can't make a bounded circumstance
and get rid of all the complexity.
It always comes sneaking back in.
So what would be an unknown?
Unknown.
This is a good one.
Here.
You have an intimate relationship.
You've had it for 10 years.
You Trust your partner,
so what does that mean?
You know where you are,
you know who you are and you have a
pretty good idea of who of where you're
going and then one day you find out that
your partner has been cheating on you.
Not with one person but with three
people and for the whole 10 years.
Well hypothetically,
that comes as a shock.
Although you may have ignored many
intimations that such might be the case
irrelevant.
Let's say it comes as a shock.
Well,
what happens to you?
you don't know where you are.
You don't know where you've been.
That's interesting gay because you think
you know where you've been because
you've already been there,
but all of a sudden something can happen
so that you are so flipped over that you
don't even know where you were.
So that means in some sense,
the past is dependent on the present,
a very peculiar thing.
You also have no idea where you're going
in terms of not knowing where you are.
That's Deep Bay because you might think,
well,
I thought it was in a marriage that
turns out to be wrong.
I thought I knew who my wife or husband
was that turns out to be wrong.
I concluded on the basis that I knew my
wife,
that I knew something about women that
turned out to be wrong.
I thought I was in a relationship with
someone I could trust that is wrong.
I don't know enough about trust.
I'm obviously too gullible.
And so what that does is throw virtually
everything that's ever happened to me in
severe doubt.
Right?
That's the emergence of chaos.
And that's
yes,
sometimes you're going from point a to
point b and something you don't expect
manifests itself in the middle of your
plan.
But it's not such a catastrophe because
you can just work around it.
And then sometimes something pops up and
like you just do not have a plan
anymore.
And so then you might ask yourself just
exactly where you are,
you when you don't know where you are,
and I would say that's a place and it's
actually a place that's well documented
in plastic,
religious and mythological stories.
That's chaos.
The Dallas,
for example,
they believe that the world is made out
of chaos and order order.
That's where you are.
When what you do gets you what you want,
chaos.
That's where you are.
When you have no idea what's going on
and you might ask,
well,
is there a way that you should act when
you're in chaos?
And the answer to that is there better
be because it's a place you're going to
visit several times during your life and
everyone visits that.
That's why it's an archetypal story.
That's the dissent to the underground.
Underground is that horrible place that
lurks underneath all of our
presuppositions.
It's the frigid lake underneath the thin
ice that everybody's skating on and it's
something that can manifest itself at
any moment.
That's partly why in the Dallas
Assemble,
the Black Paisley is chaos by the way,
and the White Paisley is ordered in the
order Paisley.
There's a little black dot.
Well,
that's because order can turn into chaos
and does at any moment,
and the reverse is also true chaos.
Paternity to order at any moment and
insight will do that for you.
You know,
alcoholics report that when they hit
bottom,
it's like there's a capella system.
They look at the world in a different
way.
You know now there are a new person,
they're back from the underground.
They've risen from the dead,
so to speak.
You know,
and it's partly because what looks like
your right hemisphere is pretty good at
inferring patterns in,
in,
in novel and chaotic places.
It's kind of keeping track of things
that happened to you that are anomalous
and it makes alternative maps of the
world that are there for you to rely on,
at least to some degree if that ever
becomes necessary.
Or you might ask yourself,
how upset should you be when something
that you don't expect happens?
Now?
It turns out that that is really a
difficult question to answer because
what the problem is is that when
something you don't expect happens,
you don't know what it is,
and so then he might say,
well,
how upset should you get an answer to
that is
you don't know,
and so what happens is,
first of all,
you're.
You've got some built in approximators.
One would be your
genetically determined level of
neuroticism,
which is basically sensitivity to
negative emotion.
If you're more sensitive to negative
emotion,
you're going to manifest more
psychophysiological preparation per unit
of threat or uncertainty,
which is to say some people get more
upset about the same thing.
Then other people do.
Now who's right?
Well who knows?
You wake up in the morning and there's a
little ache in your side.
It's like,
well,
what is that is sore muscle or cancer?
You don't know,
and if you're hypochondriacal well,
it's going to be cancer and sometimes
the hypochondriac is right,
and so he's the one that lives when he
goes to the emergency room and finds out
exactly what's going on.
So it's an unanswerable question.
Now,
the other way that your brain determines
how upset you should be is by
calculating your position in the
dominance hierarchy because the higher
you are in the dominance hierarchy,
the more resources you have at your
disposal,
and so the less upset you have to get
with anything horrible happen,
so if you're bad,
you're barely clinging to the bottom of
the social structure.
You can be sure that your brain is going
to estimate any anomalous occurrence as
a catastrophe,
which is why people don't like being at
the bottom of the dominance hierarchy
and it's also why people who were there
die a lot sooner and they do.
They die a lot sooner regardless of
their absolute level of wealth.
It's relative deprivation that counts.
Okay,
so here's a bit of a clue about how else
your brain might calculate how upset you
should be.
Here's a little map of me when I'm doing
something that I frequently do,
which is to write a manuscript.
So you might say,
well,
what are you doing when you're writing a
manuscript?
And that turns out to be a very
complicated question.
It's like,
what are you doing when you read it?
Read a book.
Well,
you're writing letters or typing them.
You're typing words and phrases.
You typing sentences,
you're typing paragraphs,
you're typing the structure that the
paragraphs fit into.
That would be the essay.
Okay.
Then you're
me.
Anyways,
I'm practicing science because I usually
write scientific manuscripts and that's
part of embodying my pref professorial
role and then that's part of
hypothetically being a productive
citizen,
although some of you might differ with
that,
given that I'm a professor and then
perhaps on outside of that or this is
what I think is on outside of that is
I'm confronting the unknown and you
might say,
well,
what are you really doing when you're
writing a sentence and the answer to
that is you're doing all of these things
better or worse and if you're doing a
really good job of writing a sentence,
you're doing all of them at once and
that would be one of the things that
would make the sentence particularly
meaningful.
Now,
if something anomalous occurs,
well,
let's say the tee on my typewriter gets
stuck,
well that's gonna irritate me because
then I can't type a sentence now,
it's not going to irritate me too much
because you know,
it doesn't really interfere with my
ability to be a productive citizen.
So I'm going to estimate the magnitude
of how upset I should be when something
unknown occurs by estimating where in
the hierarchy of action that normally is
disruptive.
Okay,
so let,
let me run you through this again.
So let's say
what's a good person and you might think
of that from an objective perspective,
but that would be a mistake because our
quality like good is a pragmatic quality
and it's based on action not on object.
So here's how you decompose being a good
person.
So
a good person is a good parent.
More than that,
that's a subcomponent right?
And good parent is someone who has a job
and takes care of their family and then
the person who takes care of their
family is like,
they can play with the baby or they can
complete a meal.
These are abstract concepts.
You can't tell a four year old make a
meal and the reason you can't,
just because they don't know the
subordinate components of making a meal,
you can say,
see that fork.
Hopefully they know what a fork is.
See that fork?
Yes,
pick up that work and bring that forth
to the table and put it there.
They can do that because their nervous
system is organized enough to operate at
that level of abstraction,
but they can't do something like make a
meal,
which is,
you know,
if you've got a three year old,
you can't put them in their room and you
say clean up your room.
He'll just look at you and then when
they come back,
when you come back in half an hour,
they'll look at you again.
You can say,
hey kid,
see that teddy bear?
Yeah,
pick up the teddy bear and put it on
that space in the wall and then once you
teach the three year old how to do 100
of those things and they got it,
they've got a little motor routines.
You can say,
clean the room.
You can encapsulate that entire set of
motor routines within the higher order
concept,
so if you're being a good person,
part of that is,
well,
maybe you're making a meal and part of
that would be while you're cutting up
the vegetables,
but then things get interesting because
when you're cutting up the vegetables,
what you're actually doing is gripping
something and moving and then that's no
longer abstract,
right?
That's where your conceptual
philosophical presuppositions like be a
good person hit the roof,
hit the hit the level of embodied
material reality.
That's the disillusion of the mind into
the body.
Now
if someone says to you,
you should cut those vegetables more
thinly,
that might irritate you,
but if they say you're a bad parent,
maybe observing the same phenomena,
then you're going to get into a fight
with them and so,
and the reason for that is obviously if
it's just a matter of cutting the
vegetables thinner,
oh,
you have to do is make a minor
modification in the hierarchy that
constitutes yourself
representation or really yourself.
It's not just a representation,
but if you're not a good parent,
it's like if that's true,
you've got a lot of.
You got a lot of repair work to do,
a lot of your world is fallen apart and
as soon as things fall apart,
which they always do,
you're in chaos and as soon as you're in
chaos,
then your body defaults to emergency
preparation and you're stressed and if
you're stressed long enough then you
die,
and so you don't like that stress.
Say when your body gets stressed,
what happens is because it doesn't
really know what's going on,
it prepares for everything.
That's the generalized stress response.
Cortisol production does that.
Cortisol production is good.
It wakes you up in the morning,
but if it's chronic,
you get old like it's so general and
it's negative actions that the best way
to conceptualize it's detrimental
longterm effect is that it accelerates
aging,
so it makes you more likely to have
heart disease and cancer and depression
and Alzheimer's and
diabetes and obesity.
That'll do.
It's enough.
Any of those that are enough to kill
you.
All right,
so there's a hierarchy.
That's a hierarchy of values.
The higher the value,
the more the less you want to have it
disrupted.
Now
was it a psychologist named piaget?
Some of you might know about him.
Piaget was very interested in what
happens to value structures and their
hierarchical organization once they have
to apply outside of the confines of a
body.
So.
So here's a way of thinking about it.
Two year olds basically hypothalamic.
That's why there's so much fun.
First they're happy,
they're sad,
then they're hungry,
then they're tired,
you know,
they just zipped from one pretty
straightforward and rather are inspiring
motivational state to another and but at
two they can't play.
They can play with by themselves,
but they can't play with other children.
They can't get that until they're three
and they need to get it by the time
they're three because if they don't get
it by the time they're four,
they will never get it.
And then you have an antisocial kid
who's going to be an outsider for his
entire life and there isn't anything you
can do about it.
So that has to happen between two and
four.
So what happens at about age three is
that the kid learns how to play a game
with another person and what that game
is,
it's fundamentally the development of
the ability to share a frame of
reference,
which is what you're doing when you play
monopoly.
It's like it's stupid to play monopoly.
Obviously,
who cares if you have a whole pile of
counterfeit paper,
right?
But doesn't matter because the way your
constituted is that your brain will
treat anything you act like constitutes
a valuable goal as if it's a valid
framework of reference.
And if it couldn't do that,
a you couldn't abstract and B,
you could not get along with other
people.
So you can sit around the table and you
can say,
let's pretend that monopoly is a
reasonable facsimile of reality,
which you wouldn't say,
but it's what you mean.
And everybody says yes,
that would be a music.
And so then you set your goal,
which is to get all the little hotels
and all the money and play with your
emotions.
Go along for the ride.
And what's so interesting about that is
you can get everybody into the game and
so one of the things that's really
interesting about people is that we can
establish a shared fictional frame of
reference and it organizes all our
emotions.
So they're predictable.
That's also why we can watch movies.
You go to a movie,
you identify the hero,
you figure out what the hero wants,
truth,
you're the hero.
And the way that works is you don't look
at the hero and think about what he's
doing and evaluated emotionally and then
feel it.
What you do is you specify the hero's
goal and then you map them onto your
body and you read off the emotional
responses of your own body.
And that's how you understand the hero.
So it's an embodied,
you're,
you're using your,
your embodiment as a computational
device that can run simulations of other
consciousnesses.
And it does that with the body.
And we like doing that.
You can go to a movie and you know
you're Brad Pitt for an hour and a half.
You know,
when you're Brad Pitt doing remarkable
things.
And that's also how we understand other
people were very good at that.
So anyways,
we have these shared frames of reference
like when we were playing monopoly,
okay.
So children at three learn how to play
games and that means they learn how to
organize their own internal motivational
states into a hierarchy that includes
the motivational states of other people.
And that means they can play.
And that's what you guys do when you're
out in the world.
Like we're playing a game right now.
We all know the rules.
That's why we can all sit in this room
and play the game without fighting with
each other.
You know,
in the room is set up like a theater and
we all know the theater game and so.
And the chairs are always facing this
way at the moment.
And so that's a hint that you should
look forward and this is raised so you
know,
the room is basically telling you what
to do because it's a stage like all
rooms.
And because you're smart and socially
conscious,
you can walk into a stage,
grew and your body knows what to do and
if you're civilized in social,
you just do it.
Then all the other primates can predict
what you're up to and they won't kill
you.
Yeah,
well that's what it means to be part of
the same tribe.
You know when people are very peculiar
creatures and God only knows what
they're up to,
but as long as they're playing the same
game you are.
You don't have to know what they're up
to because you can predict what they're
going to do and you understand their
motivational states and so part of the
building and constructing of higher
order motive,
higher order moral goals,
is the establishment of joint frames of
reference that allow multiple people to
pursue the goals that they're interested
in simultaneously.
And then what you have to think about
with regards to that is that not all
shared frames of reference can manage
that.
There's a small subset of them that are
optimized so that not only can multiple
people play them,
but multiple people can play them and
enjoy them.
And do it repeatedly across a long
period of time,
so it's integratability that partly
defines the utility of a higher order
moral structure and that is not
arbitrary.
It's an emergent property of biological
interactions and you might say,
well,
it's kind of arbitrary because people
can do what they want,
but it's not arbitrary at all because a
lot of what's constraining your games is
your motivational substructure and those
ancient circuits that are status
oriented and they operate within
virtually every animal has a status.
Counter creatures organize themselves
into dominance hierarchies.
The reason they do that is because that
works.
It's a solution.
It's a solution to the Darwinian problem
of existence.
It's not just an empathy phenomena.
It's the real thing.
So you,
your environment,
fundamentally a huge chunk of your
environment is dominance hierarchy plus
God only knows where you are and that's
order and chaos.
And part of the reason that people fight
to preserve their dominance hierarchies
is because it's better to be a slave.
Who knows what the hell is going on than
someone who's thrown screaming and naked
into the jungle at night.
And that's the difference between order
and chaos,
and we like order better than chaos and
it's no wonder now we'll invite a little
chaos in for entertainment now and then.
But it has to be done voluntarily.
And generally you don't want the kind of
chaos that upsets your entire conceptual
structure.
You know,
you're willing to fool around on the
fringes a little bit,
but you know when the going gets
serious,
you're pretty much likely to bail out
and no wonder.
Now I wanted to tell you a little bit
about
this chaotic domain.
I can tell you a couple of things about
it.
It's the underworld of mythology.
One of the things that's kind of
interesting about the underworld is that
it has a suburb and one of the suburbs
of the underworld is hell and hell is
the place where you end up when
everything that you know falls apart and
you get resentful and bitter about it.
And that's very,
like I.
One of the things I've noticed in my
work as a clinical psychologist,
that there's two things that really do
people in three lying.
That's not good.
Apart from that resentment and
arrogance,
if you get resentful enough,
you end up like Elliot Rogers and all
those other people who go on random
shooting sprees because they have a
disagreement about the structure of the
exist of existence and the fact that
they ended up hypothetically at the
bottom of the heap,
so those are real places and people get
stuck in them and they are not places
that you would voluntarily choose to go
if you had any sense at all,
and I'll tell you,
if you read the accounts of the people
who do random mass murder,
they'll tell you exactly where they are
and they'll tell you exactly what
they're motivated to do and what they're
motivated to do is take as much revenge
on existence as they possibly could.
Imagine in the most unfair possible way,
as fast as they can possibly manage it,
and that's their conscious aim and he
says,
not a form of insanity.
They know exactly what they're doing.
They have a.
They have a precise idea of what they're
in the APP and it's a deep archetypal
possession,
for lack of a better word.
Now
I want to show you how some of these
things are mapped
symbolically.
They're not really symbols in my
estimation because assemble implies that
something is being represented.
You know that there's a reality behind
the representation that's broader than
the representation and assemble is just
a shadow of it.
These aren't symbols.
Their representations that are as
accurate as they can possibly be.
I'll start with something that's rather
easy to understand.
Let's try.
Yes.
What happens when you look at her
Medusa?
You turned to stone.
What happens when your rabbit sees a
wolf?
That's right.
It turns to stone.
The Medusa is a symbol.
It's a representation of all those
things that make you turn to stone.
When you look at them.
Now,
look,
animals can deal with threat,
right?
They have instincts to deal with threat,
but zebras,
maybe there's a bunch of zebras and
they're out there and heard and there's
a bunch of lines and they're right
there,
and the zebras,
what are they doing?
They're grazing and you think,
wow,
those zebras aren't very bright because
there's a bunch of lions,
like,
why aren't they,
you know,
in the forest building a Fort Pete Lyons
out,
but they,
the reason they're not doing that is
because although they can react to
threat,
they cannot conceive to the of the class
of threatening objects.
Now human beings can conceive of the
class of threatening objects and so what
civilization is in large part is an
attempt to find a remedy for the class
of threatening objects.
Now there are representations of those
sorts of things.
The Medusa is one of them.
The reason it's feminine is very
difficult to explain and I don't think I
have the time unfortunately,
but you'll have to take my word for it.
You see the little cartoon of Robert
Crumb off to the left there and he's got
a big eatable problem,
old rob chrome.
And the problem with him fundamentally
as his mother was something like a giant
spider and did everything she possibly
could to crush the life out of him
hands,
his remaining relationship with women.
And so that's part of the reason why the
femininity can be a
something that turns you to stone.
It's an experience that many men are
familiar with by the way,
because the average man is rejected far
more often than he's accepted.
And since women are the gateway to
reproduction,
they constitute nature itself.
And Nature itself tells most men you
should go home and stay under your bed.
There's lots of experiments done about
this.
So for example,
psychologists have an undergraduate
woman go out into the concourse and see
how long it takes.
Someone heard to find someone who agrees
to sleep with her.
Now it takes like,
you know,
two seconds after she asks the first man
and then,
and then they flip it,
you know,
and they get your random undergraduate
guy to do the same thing.
It's well,
you could imagine the consequences of
that since many of you men have lived
through it,
mother nature with a woman wears the
face of Mother Nature and the face his
generally rejecting,
especially to men who are low in the
dominance hierarchy by the way,
which is one of the things that
irritates guys like Elliot Rogers and
one of the things that motivates their
desire to take revenge.
That's a universal phenomenon,
so that's part of the reason that the
feminine is nature and why nature.
By the way,
his mother nature is like,
it's diagnosis of your status is not
good enough and no wonder
what seems to have happened
fundamentally is that these domains that
I talked to you about,
which can be represented as chaos and
order,
say an r from the that was perspective
can also be represented as masculine and
feminine.
And I think the reason for that is that
human beings are fundamentally social
primates,
right?
We're very,
very social and we know that one of the
correlates of brain size in primates,
the social group size,
and we also know that most primates say
chimps who were quite closely related to
they don't like go out and investigate
leaves and you know period things
through microscopes.
They spend all their time interacting
with other chimpanzees.
Although they're chewing all the time.
They do it because they have a
ridiculously ineffective,
you know,
digestive and an eating system.
Their brain is adapted
to the social circumstances as the
primary reality.
So you could say,
well,
tribe is the primary reality and then
there's a secondary reality which is all
that which is outside tribe and that
corresponds to chaos and order.
Order in contradiction to chaos is
symbolized by masculine symbols.
And that's for example why etiologies
like radical feminism presume the
existence of a patriarchy.
It fits into the symbolic structure of
our minds.
That idea,
and it's true in some sense because just
like in chimpanzee troops,
the primary or Metta hierarchy that
makes up human civilization is
fundamentally masculine in its origin
and structure and so masculine is
fundamentally the dominance hierarchy.
And Feminine is some fundamentally all
the things that are outside or that
challenged the dominance hierarchy and
so it's,
and it's a perfectly reasonable,
it's weird a because our brain is
organized to fundamentally apprehend the
world in terms of personalities and
that's partly because you know,
as we've emerged over the course of
evolution,
it's been relatively constant that there
were males around and that there were
females around and that the males were
fathers and that the females were
mothers and you know,
that they were both mates as well.
It's a constant of the evolutionary
landscape and that's what our brains
evolved to process.
And then what happened when we developed
the capacity to abstract is we use this
underlying social cognitive abstraction
structure to start to represent the
structure of being itself.
So we could say,
well,
there's a dominance hierarchy in that
society and that's masculine and there's
all the things that challenge the
dominance hierarchy and they're outside
in their feminine.
The weirdest thing about that,
however,
is that it actually works.
You know,
we've got away with that for some
reason.
It seems to be perfectly reasonable to
map the world in that manner.
It keeps us going.
All right,
I'm going to try to explain this.
This is nail chemical symbol
at the bottom of the symbol.
There's this round thing with wings.
Do you ever see Harry Potter?
Yeah.
You know the game quidditch.
You remember what they chase chase a
gold one of those.
All right,
so they call that the snitch,
I believe,
and there's little fragment of soil and
it's very interesting idea because for
the alchemists,
the primary element of reality,
whatever that was could be
conceptualized as this thing is round
chaos and what it was conceptualized
have in part was
it was a container from which matter and
spirit could emerge and what you might
ask,
well,
what does that mean?
This is what it means.
When a child experiences something,
it can't predict.
It does the thing that led to that
uncertain outcome over and over and over
and over until it can map it,
and then you think,
well,
what did the child do?
What the child did was take the domain
of that which it did not understand and
it transformed it into matter,
which is the predictable world of
entities and spirit,
which is the internal psychological
structure that's adapted to that,
and so what the alchemists basically
conceptualized was that
what exists outside of your conceptual
framework is something like unrealized
potential,
and when you interact with that
unrealized potential,
you actualize it and you actualize it
into two component elements,
one being the material world and the
other being your own psychological
structure.
That's why they conceptualized matter
and spirit,
container of matter and spirit as the
ultimate reality,
and out of that emerged something that
was quite primordial,
which is the dragon.
Now,
one of the things we know
you remember in the genesis story,
it's the snake that gives people vision.
Do you remember?
It gives him wisdom and it also produces
selfconsciousness.
There's a woman named Lynn Isabelle,
who's an anthropologist in La and she
was very interested in human being site
because we can really see,
we can see better than any other
creature except predatory birds.
We can see way better than most
primates.
Isabelle knew that our tree dwelling
ancestors,
some 60 million years ago,
emerged at about the same time as
snakes.
They're younger than lizards by the way,
and that we were preyed on quite
intensely by snakes for tens of millions
of years,
and she also knew that we were good at
detecting snakes in the bottom of our
visual field,
and then we were particularly good at
protecting the camouflage patterns of
snakes and the bottom of our visual
field.
So she did a series of field experiments
showing that primate visual acuity was
correlated strongly with the presence of
predatory snakes in the immediate
environment.
So the idea that snakes gave us vision
is right now,
why is that relevant to this?
We were preyed upon for a very long
period of time and we developed a neural
circuit to deal with predators and
that's the neural circuit that's
activated and children when they're
terrified about monsters at night.
So the Predator entity,
which is this dragon,
it's like a.
it's like an amalgam of predatory forces
is one of the manifestations of the
things that exist outside of the
dominance hierarchy.
So it's a.
it's a form of primordial reality.
It's not abstract anymore like the
matter and spirit container.
It's like the first practical
manifestation of what's terrifying and
threatening concretely outside that,
and so remember,
animals can respond to threat,
but they can't conceptualize threat as a
category.
That's the conceptualization of threat
as a category.
It emerges from the absolute unknown.
It manifests itself as threat.
So for example,
if you hear a loud noise behind you or a
grow when you're in the forest,
the first thing that happens is you
don't know what's going on and that's
the initial state of contact with
potential and then if you turn around
and you look,
that potential manifests itself into
something that's predatory and you have
a circuit for that and that's the same
circuit that we now use to assess
anything unexpected that it occurs to us
and I think that circuit had become from
somewhere.
And so our capacity to respond to
surprising entities is an elaboration
elaboration up into abstraction of our
capacity to identify predators.
So that's the next level of reality.
And out of that chaotic circumstance
comes something that's more human and
that that is the emergence of
masculinity and femininity out out of
that more primordial element.
Okay.
Let me show you two things.
This is a map of
pragmatic territory as far as I can
tell.
It's the territory that people actually
inhabit at the first level.
It's the square I called that the dragon
of chaos.
That's the unknown as such,
and it's the thing that you fall into
when you're conceptual schemes fall
apart.
What manifests itself out of that is
femininity and femininity comes in two
forms.
One is benevolent femininity.
Example would be
this.
You see Mary on the left there.
She's in a structure called a man door
lock,
which is from a Freudian perspective,
has obvious sexual connotations.
You see,
if you look carefully that she's
standing on a reptile and holding her
child away from it.
That's a common medieval Christian
image.
You can think of it as divine because
women's spent an awful lot of time doing
that with their children over the course
of our millions of years of evolution.
And it's something that's sacred because
our species dependent on that for its
for its survival,
this one's even better.
This is a medieval image.
I love this image.
So there's Mary with the Christ child
and she standing again on a reptile
predatory rep top,
but in the background you see all those
weird little shapes.
Those are musical instruments and that
they feel space and the medieval artists
who drew this picture had this
intimation that behind the manifestation
that something as primary as the
protective maternity of Mary was
something like the music of the spheres
or are a collection of harmonious
patterns and that this figure was
constantly emerging out of that
background of harmonious patterns across
the infinite stretches of time itself.
That's the sacred image because it
represents something that human society
cannot live without.
Like any society that doesn't regard the
Virgin and the Child Who protects the
child from the predatory serpent as a
prime element of sacred reality is going
to make itself estate.
You know,
I could say for example,
that that's what's happening to the
indigenous populations of eastern Europe
at the moment where their birth rate is
far below replacement.
I'm going to show you another image.
This is called a village or open virgin
and it was a common representation in
medieval Europe and it's a weird
representation from a Christian
perspective because it kind of reverses
the normal hierarchy of power.
What you have here is Mary,
she's holding the Christ child when the
statute was closed and then you open her
out.
Why don't you see inside Mary is God the
father and God the father is holding
Christ in his hands.
Now
Mary constitutes the superordinate
benevolent feminine.
Inside her is the structure of culture,
so you can think inside nature is the
structure of culture and that's
represented in this image by God because
he's the ultimate father obviously and
Christian thinking,
and then the God figure is holding what?
Crucified individual.
What does that mean?
Now all the people around their kings,
Queens,
commenters are all gazing at that
central figure,
which of course is fundamentally what
everyone in western civilization has
been doing for 2000 years.
Not knowing why
nature gives rise to culture.
Culture gives rise to the suffering
individual.
Well,
that's true enough.
It's true for everyone.
It's true for life at every point in
time,
but there's more to the image of the
crucifixion because crucifixion also
represents voluntary acceptance of
suffering and voluntary acceptance of
death,
and it also points to something else
that's of paramount importance,
which is that there's an element of the
human psyche that can die and come back
and die and come back.
And that's what happens to you.
When you encounter a catastrophe and you
make order of it and you climb back out
of the underworld and your.
Your voice through life is punctuated by
trips to the underworld.
And so you're somewhere and then you go
outside that and then you go somewhere
else and then you go outside that.
And so what happens to people is they
generally identify with where they are
order,
but order dissolves and collapses,
and then it reconstitutes itself.
So then you might say,
if you are trying to adapt to the
structure of reality itself,
instead of identifying with order,
you would identify with a process that
allowed you to transform yourself across
repeated bouts of order and chaos.
And that's what these sorts of images or
trying to represent.
So
let me show you
one final idea.
Here's a taoist idea that's like this.
So the Dallas symbol,
you know the dallas symbol,
I already talked to you about it and
you've all seen it.
Chaos and order,
man,
masculine and feminine,
constantly in interplay.
That's Dow from the Taoist perspective.
And Dow is the source of meaning.
So the idea there is that it's the
constant interplay between chaos and
order that produces the sense of meaning
and human beings.
And that's true.
That is what produces the sense of
meaning.
You know that because when you're
engaged in a compelling operation,
you're partly ordered and secure and you
have one foot out into the unknown and
the balance is proper and as a
consequence you're engaged in what
you're doing and then as a consequence
of that,
you lose your self consciousness and if
you stay engaged in that sort of
situation on a continual basis,
then that you find that your life is
meaningful and rich and that's the best
antidote to the fact that life is
bounded and full of suffering.
Now,
Tao means meaning.
It also means journey and the center of
the Tao is the place you're supposed to
be one foot in chaos and one foot in
order and that's the best place to be in
the actual environment itself.
Because the actual environment is better
construed as the constant interplay
between chaos and order than it is
construed as a collection of material
objects.
And if you adopt the pragmatic view that
points out that there are metta
realities above the mirror objects that
we perceive.
You can also apprehend that our brains
are actually adapted to the Metta
realities and not.
The reality is because our brains are
like $300,
million years old and what we've done is
extracted out those things that are
constant,
that cross spends of times,
fans of kinds that are hundreds of
millions of years in length and those
aren't chairs and tables are
automobiles.
There they're metal structures that are
much more sophisticated than that and we
ignore that at our peril because modern
people don't believe that meaning
exists.
They think it's EPA.
Phenomenal.
There's nothing subjective about our
worldview when in fact our nervous
systems are tuned so that life is
manifesting itself in the most
meaningful possible way.
When you happen to be occupying the
precise position between chaos and order
that maximizes your security and the
development of that security across
time,
and that's not.
That's the most real thing there is,
and to stay in that position is also to
accept voluntarily the necessity for a
certain degree of suffering.
Because as you extend your capacities by
exposing yourself to the optimal level
of the unknown,
you're constantly taking yourself apart
and rebuilding yourself,
and that's what allows you to thrive not
only in the presence of stability,
but also in a state that consists of the
transformation of that stability.
Here's a representation for maintenance
Egypt.
These are representations of Horace.
There's a lot of evidence that many of
the ideas we have about Christ or
derivatives of Egyptian ideas,
most people who point that out
pointed out in a manner same debt,
devaluing
the ideas that were derived from ego
because they have an a priori motive,
which is a destructive motive.
As mythology progresses across the
centuries,
it transforms itself and attempts to
continually encapsulate Rayanne
capsulate.
The primary idea is that the human race
has managed to produce about the
structure of reality itself.
There's constant sees across these
cultural manifestations because the
reality too,
which they route to which they refer,
is actually reality.
Horace,
this is a good lesson and I'll leave you
with this horse,
is the eye.
The eye is not the intellect.
The intellect is the thing that forces
everything into a preexisting structure
and it crunches reality.
To do that at warp it and twists it and
it makes people ideological and rigid.
The eye is something completely
different.
The I is the thing that pays attention
and your attention is automatically
directed to those elements of your
experiential field where the most
information is manifesting itself.
That's why,
for example,
if you're talking to someone in a bar
and there's a TV flickering,
you can't help but look at the TV that
change,
that transformation is what your nervous
system is attuned to and the theory is
that if you're a follower of horace,
who is the I and the Vulcan because
Falcons can see and they fly above
everything else.
If you're a follower of horace,
you pay attention.
When you pay attention,
you absorb information.
When you absorb information,
you continually transform yourself and
that keeps you on top of it ever.
Shifting reality.
Doing that is meaningful and that's what
stops you from becoming bitter and cruel
because you know life is suffering.
You know,
and if you don't have an antidote to
that suffering that's real,
then you become resentful about the
structure of experience and then you'll
do everything you can to take revenge on
it.
And we saw what happened when people did
that in the 20th century and it would be
a good thing if people woke up and stop
doing it and as far as I can tell after
fig trying to figure this out for like
30 years.
The way that you do that is by paying
attention and transforming yourself when
it's necessary and stopping the process
of identifying with what you already
believe.
Who the hell cares what you believe you
should be attending to the things you
don't know,
which is a much larger space than the
things you know and then you should be
construing yourself.
Not as the inhabitant of a sterile and
static and already completed structure,
but as the thing that lives on the edge
of that.
That's constantly building and
rebuilding it and then if something
happens to your structure,
it's not so relevant because that's not
what you are.
You're the thing that can engage in
transformations of structure by paying
attention,
and that's what these representations
mean.
These are renaissance pictures.
You know they've elevated the entity
that voluntarily accepts the necessity
of suffering and death,
so that's represented by Christ to the
highest position in the heavenly
hierarchy.
What that idea means is that what should
constitute the transcendent value that
sits above all other values
is your capacity to voluntarily accept
they're restricted and painful
conditions of your life.
To face them and as a consequence of
facing them immediately transcend them.
Now,
one of the things we know from clinical
psychology is that if you have someone
who's afraid
they avoid,
so what do you do about that?
You break down the thing they're afraid
of til you find a small unit that take
an approach.
When they approach it,
they learned that they can approach it
and that they're more than they thought
they were,
and then they can approach the next
thing and then the next thing,
and so you take a woman who's got agora
phobia who can't get into an elevator
and a week later she can and then she
goes home and has the fight with her
husband that she should have had 20
years ago,
and the reason for that is that when
she's exposed to the things that she's
afraid of,
instead of running from them,
she learns that she's the thing that can
be exposed to things she's afraid of.
She doesn't learn that things aren't
frightening and learning the thing.
She's the thing that can be exposed to
things that are frightening made sir
more than the frightening things.
And it's certainly possible that we're
more than the things that frightened us.
If we weren't,
we wouldn't be here.
We shouldn't throw these things away
before we understand them and we're in
danger of doing that now.
So part of what I've been trying to do
in my lectures and my work is to point
out what our forefathers new to try to
help modern people understand it and to
make the case that these things that we
think of as
non real representations are more real
than anything that we currently
comprehend as real.
That
consequences of not comprehending them
and living by them as far as I can tell
is that things deteriorate and they can
deteriorate to a point where everything
is intolerable for everyone.
And that seems to be a sub optimal
destination.
So
thanks for the invitation.
Thank you.